all right kirk cousins is in minnesota
for their offseason workouts and he has
the playbook we had an image of the
playbook during pft live it is gigantic
it is it is one of those big giant
binders that's so big there it is why do
why
why do you even use a binder that big
have has anyone out there to ever try to
carry around one of those binders it's
all slick and it wants to slide out of
your hands and it's heavy yeah i haven't
had binders like that would say let's
just have a second volume folks yeah i
mean it's hard to read it and you get
the and you to take that one page and
you almost rip it out of the three-ring
binders you're trying to it's pissing me
off yeah just looking at that pisses me
off and apart from the fact that it's
killing trees chris i know you've got
the you know the
the the green new deal sensibilities
it affects me because it's a pain in the
ass carrying the thing around yeah well
i mean it is ludicrous yes at the very
base level it bothers me because yes i
am very green pro environment and i
think that's half of the brazil
rainforest that's right there in that
playbook so that pisses me off and the
digital age where everything is capable
of being put on an ipad or all that just
a waste it's a waste it's a disrespect
of life it's everything that's what i
don't understand but then the playbook
itself these are just off-season
playbooks i'll say that to you mike like
this will not be the playbook that you
have during the season during the season
you get a week-to-week type of playbook
much smaller better
easier to manage but a lot of that stuff
in that playbook is nonsense like
there's gonna be play things there that
kirk cousins is gonna go okay i learned
that in fourth grade i learned this in
fifth grade whatever it may be they're
gonna teach people you know there's
gonna be four pages on how the
quarterback says the you know the the
the signal calling blue 85 blue 85 and
what it means to go on two and what's
our hard count and what's that's gonna
be a lot of pages on that there's gonna
be pages on how to line up in the huddle
and do stuff like that uh so there's
gonna be a lot of base level crap on
there that's not really for the kirk
cousins that that stuff is for the
rookie the free agent who's just getting
his way into the organization and he
needs to learn some of the base level
stuff uh but it is a lot of nonsense and
totally not necessary to be that big or
on paper
that's all the more reason to have a
second volume put all the basic crap in
one volume and put the actual plays and
another volume and put it all on an ipad
that it's 2019 folks who carries around
that kind of paper anymore i use no
paper whatsoever the only time i use
paper chris is when we are in the nbc
viewing room on sundays they put pads of
paper out there for us to make notes on
while we're while we're watching uh the
games and and i'll make notes there on
like things that we're chasing stories
that we're trying to follow up on people
we want to talk to questions for those
guys i don't even need to do that i just
do it because it's there but it's one
little pad of paper it's not this just
carrying around this giant binder with
all these pages and it really is amazing
to me that the vikings are doing that
and it's amazing to me that kirk cousins
is being so candid about this process he
said at one point yesterday it's like
learning offense all over again how can
the new offense be so different that
it's like going back to square one yeah
i i don't think it's back to square one
i think he might be embellishing there
maybe trying to
you know
toot the horn the new offensive
coordinator up there in minnesota to go
you know he's got his new vibe new
things going on we're learning all you
know the intricacies of his offense but
you know yeah for a guy like kirk
cousins who's been in kyle shanahan's
system you know been with sean mcvay
been with jay gruden there's not going
to be anything in there that he's never
learned everything he's there he knows
already for the most part there might be
a few rules here and there to apply that
oh this is different than what i did in
washington whatever it may be but at the
very uh at the very least yes he's a
very well-schooled quarterback there's
not going to be anything that is going
to be groundbreaking new uh and he's
been taught just about every play and
every read in the history of football
with some of the offensive minds he's
been before it's more about just
learning the language and those type of
things that i'm sure he's trying to have
to figure out more than anything right
now
i'll repeat what i said during the show
i hope there's a page in there that that
says how to win primetime games you're
such an exact and maybe they won't have
many this year see when you underachieve
you don't get a bunch of prime time
games but they're still going to have
big games i like how mike zimmer
explained it to us at the league
meetings hey the reason that we
struggled in those prime time games
you're usually playing a pretty good
team that's right prime time but if you
want to be a really good team you've got
to be able to beat the pretty good teams
you can't go two and six in your big
games they had eight big games last year
they went two and six maybe i'll throw
in week two two six and one the tie
against the packers and i feel like that
loss because of missed field goals and
other crap yeah i think that that
derailed the season for the vikings they
lost the bills the next week but uh
bottom line is they got to win big games
and they don't need to do it with a
big-ass playbook nice they don't and
then yes let's move on to the two like
you said 2019 and just find the ipad for
everybody please
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports